for today's classic interview we are
delving into the topic of revolution
back in 2015 August of 2015 I
interviewed James Pierson and the topic
was what will cause the next American
Revolution and now with all of the talk
of the resistance and a fighting back
against this authoritarian slide that we
are seeing I can think of no better
moment to review this conversation with
James Pearson from 2015 about the next
American Revolution let's get into it
I'm joined today by James Pearson
president of the William East Simon
foundation and author of the new book
shattered consensus the rise and decline
of America's post-war political order
the book is so interesting because at
the macro level I agree with so much of
what you're saying but maybe not
surprisingly as a progressive at the
micro level I disagree with a lot of the
explanations you give and solutions you
suggest to the problem that we're facing
so let's start at the beginning describe
what what you picture as the coming
challenge to the United States of
America okay thank you David appreciate
inviting me to be on well first of all
this book is a collection of my recent
essays including several essays that
address the political economic challenge
facing especially the United States but
some other Western countries as well I
include a long essay called America's
fourth revolution in which I lay out
this general historical view that we
have had in the United States three
distinctive systems of political economy
under the Constitution the Jeffersonian
political economy sort of organized
around slavery and cotton exports that
disintegrated in the Civil War the
Republican industrial small government
system from the Civil War that
evaporated in the Great Depression and
then thirdly the post-war
a democratic welfare Keynesian system
that was created in the 30s and 40s and
which is now roughly seven years old and
my thought is that this system is
evaporating much like the Jeffersonian
and Republican industrial systems
evaporated before them after roughly a
lifetime of being in existence so this
is fast let's pause there for a second
this is fascinating because on our
program we've talked about this sort of
progression of economies through an
agriculture and farming based economy
which is similar to what you're talking
about in terms of the cotton based in
slavery status quo of 1800 into a sort
of Industrial Revolution and
manufacturing economy which is also
again what you talked about and then as
the into more of a service industry type
based economy which we now are concerned
is evaporating because of automation and
the elimination flat-out elimination of
so many both manufacturing and service
jobs so there's a lot of overlap in the
sort of hypothesis that I've outlined
and the one that you've outlined but yet
we come from very different perspectives
in terms of what caused this right well
let me just qualify I think what you've
just said is a valid historical
interpretation of what's happened but I
emphasize the political element okay
which is just say that these transitions
have occurred partly heavily through
political interventions right and that
these assistance of political economy
were carried forward and implemented by
one particular political party which
organized the coalition's to support
them in the pre Civil War period it was
the Democratic Party of Jefferson and
Jackson and the post-civil war period it
was the Republican party of Lincoln
McKinley and the presidents of the 20s
and the post-war period it was the
Democratic Party of FDR Kennedy and
Johnson EE we won't get into the reagan
rebel
solution which i think is important but
my idea is that these things don't
happen naturally as a consequence of
evolution in the economy there are
political interventions which are
important and I think that's the case
now why do I think the current system is
unwinding the Keynesian welfare state
system why is it unwinding well I point
to several things one demographics we
have a baby boom generation retiring and
drawing Social Security to put burdens
on the government we already have a
heavy debt not only governmental debt
but private sector debt and we have a
slow growing economy ever since the bust
of 2000 we've been growing at about a 2
percent rate I don't think that gets the
job done for the United States and we
have increasing political polarization
the parties cannot convene and agree on
any solution to any of these problems
either to stimulate growth or solve the
entitlement problem or anything which
means that all these crises will
escalate to a point where we we can't
avoid them any longer and that will
require a kind of a political transition
so let me let me jump in here because
you sort of settle out there I
completely agree with you that we seem
to be approaching the sort of
precipitous of beginning of an unwinding
of our economic status quo and I would
agree as the result of the political
system except when I think about it I
think not of the these sort of factors
that you talked about Italy at least not
not primarily I think about for example
the incredible wealth and income
inequality that we have and you actually
reference something you described as the
inequality hoax so let's explore that
what what is the inequality hoax in your
minds well the the title of that chapter
in my book is the inequality crisis in
quotes I wrote a short pamphlet called
the inequality hoaxed right I think
that's too strong the inequality problem
is real ok
there's no question about that that's
good good doesn't mean agree on that
there's no question about that and I
referenced
my essay the question is what's caused
it why is it happening and what do we do
about it and I argue in my book that
really the reason this is happening is
an unprecedented boom in the financial
markets that began in the early 1980s
bonds and stocks for the past 35 years
of deliberate incredible returns it's
unprecedented in human history in 1980
the valuation of world stock markets was
less than two trillion dollars it's well
in excess of 60 trillion dollars today
it's gigantic
who owns financial asset stocks and
bonds well the wealthy do primarily of
course they're owned by a pension funds
and endowments as well but in terms of
individuals
it's the wealthy they the top one
percent probably owns 50 percent of the
stocks and bonds out there a little bit
less than that closer to 40 percent
absolutely that's the real cause of the
wealth and income inequality anyone
closed the financial markets it's done
well well but that's that's part of it
though James right we're throw-in if you
throw one in the global economy I think
the global economy is partly responsible
for the surge in stock and bond
valuations that's one of the factors
because our companies get their profits
internationally much more than they did
40 or 50 years ago but James let me
pause for a second let me pause for a
second let me pause for a second because
I don't want to get too far off track
without having a chance to sort of dig
in a little deeper there's no question
that the heavy concentration of stock
and bond ownership among the rich has
further concentrated net worth among the
rich absolutely agree with you you're
spot-on with the with the numbers no
question about it but we can't ignore
that
even removing retirement contributions
and just focusing on base compensation
we have seen a drastic separation in
terms of base compensation from the
highest and lowest paid individuals
within companies and that's a huge
factor as well yeah I think that's
that's a significant factor it's not the
dominating factor but
a significant factor thomas piketty's in
his book has a interesting explanation
of that my view of that would be that a
lot of those salaries though are linked
to stock market valuations you know in
the clinton years they the federal
government limited the amount of
tax-deductible compensation that could
be paid to executives and instead they
went in the direction of pain executives
via stock options sure
the explosion of stock options obviously
exploded the compensation of these
executives in other words the clinton
administration tried to close one door
and they opened up a huge door on the
other side so I think that's also true
of executives saying not for profit
industries or in universities private
universities with gigantic endowments
are paying their presidents very large
sums of money so what you say is correct
up to a point but you know I think still
the dominating factor is the explosion
in the financial asset markets now I
believe we're going to cure the problem
I want to talk about how that might
happen because what it's very it's very
simple it's happening today tell us how
the stock market will crack and that
will resolve this issue in what way a
great deal yeah but long term Don Jane
hold on hold on
if you generally have a positive outlook
on the future of the United States it's
hard to imagine a future that doesn't
include the continued valuation of
American stocks we've seen Corrections
like the one we've seen over the last
week many times before they typically
happen yearly in fact but if you believe
that the country will exist the the
stock market is going to rebound I don't
know that that's the solution well let
me sit back I meant that sarcastically
or ironically okay does it say we can
solve the inequality problem very simply
by crashing the stock market
nobody wants that to happen alright so
what is the cure for the inequality
problem if that
taken off the table and I agree with
nobody wants to see that happen
we do have Corrections we're probably in
the middle of one now the other thing I
would say about that is that you know we
do have a slow growing economy the
Federal Reserve the monetary authorities
have spent a lot of ammunition that they
have in keeping the markets up when they
go down I don't know that they're I'm
not sure they're going to be able to
levitate them back up very quickly we'll
see about that
that's that somewhere out in the future
but I would say and I've argued that
inequality income and wealth inequality
is built in to the regime of political
economy that we built in the West since
19th 1980
there is no question about that I could
not agree with you more and we have so
much more to discuss and unfortunately
today we're out of time we will
absolutely have James Pearson back he's
president of the William E Simon
foundation the new book is called
shattered consensus the rise and decline
of America's post-war political order
thank you so much for talking to us
David that thanks for having me I'd be
happy to come on again appreciate it